empecemos por Cuáles son las
conclusiones principales de su informe
Buenas tardes la situación en Haití
lastimosamente se ha deteriorado en los
últimos años hasta llegar al punto en el
que estamos hoy donde la situación es
realmente catastrófica estamos hablando
de que cerca de la mitad de la población
haitiana o sea 4.7 millones de personas
están en inseguridad alimentaria ya sea
crisis emergencia o por primera vez en
la historia de Haití catastrófica
entonces hablamos de un millón 800 mil
personas ya en estado de emergencia de
hambre y unas 20.000 personas en la zona
metropolitana de sipeso ley que están Ya
en un nivel el más alto de la escala de
catástrofe
Y qué salidas habría esta crisis
multifacética en que como dicen en su
informe todo está conectado no la crisis
de suministros con la de seguridad o la
de salud
efectivamente el pueblo haitiano está
viviendo múltiples crisis desde todos
los ángulos incluyendo también en el sur
en zonas agrícolas
donde se ha visto muy poca lluvia y
pérdida de cosechas recordemos que el
año pasado un terremoto que afectó a
mucha población también del sur todavía
se está recuperando entonces debemos
realmente trabajar por un lado en la
asistencia humanitaria de emergencia y
por otro lado dar respuesta a lo que es
el desarrollo a largo plazo debemos
trabajar juntos es un desafío enorme y
país está en un momento tumultuoso
realmente tenemos que enfocarnos todos
en el pueblo más pobre más vulnerable de
Haití en estos momentos y precisamente
usted hacía referencia a esta asistencia
de emergencia y respecto a esto el
Primer Ministro Ariel Enric pidió que la
comunidad internacional mandara tropas
al país para restablecer la seguridad
una petición apoyada por otro lado por
el calendario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez ustedes lo ven como una
solución
la crisis política realmente es un
factor importante en lo que está
viviendo Haití hoy pero no es el único
la inseguridad ha aumentado
increíblemente más los otros problemas
que hemos mencionado nosotros como
agencia humanitaria trabajamos de manera
independiente
sin contar con los temas políticos Por
supuesto que queremos una resolución
pacífica y rápida por el pueblo haitiano
que hoy está viviendo una catástrofe